In this unit, we will be working with Monte Carlo approaches because we're looking at
NP complete problems and actually as you will see there is not that many algorithms using randomness
for NP complete problems anyway and one I'm going to show you
in more detail is a Monte Carlo algorithm.
Now the important thing about a Monte Carlo algorithm is this here, the probability.
Now of course it would be great if the probability with which we get the best possible solution
would be some constant because then we would have a very good algorithm
as the next quiz will show you.
So say we have a Monte Carlo algorithm with probability 1/2, how often do we need to run it
until we are 99.9% certain that we have the best possible answer
and please enter your answer here in this box.
Now if you don't feel comfortable with probabilities, of course, you can also skip ahead,
but even if you just have a basic knowledge of probabilities, you can probably get this one.